the screen buggy show with how Rudnick
that's me
hi everybody welcome to another episode
of the screen junkies show today got
something really serious to discuss
taking two is coming out Liam Neeson's
family gets taken again for real
Schindler's List
you could save all those Jews by the way
thank you but you can't save your family
from those Albanian sex traffickers
that's got me thinking if it could
happen to Liam Neeson that can happen to
anyone so we gathered some professionals
to help educate all of us on how not to
get taken for the first time or the
second time or god help us the third
time mark you are the security guard
here in this building yes sir
basically kind of like mall security for
this building well it is a little more
in-depth than that I was in the army
mark quite frankly I brought you here
make fun of it now I know you're a
military guy so maybe you can help me
out here
my niece is going to Eastern Europe mark
let's face it she's going to get taken
it's happened twice to Liam Neeson's
family and she doesn't what do you want
it was a movie but go ahead what will I
have to do to enable me to go all Liam
Neeson do you know basic self defense
no I don't you might want to start there
how are you doing I'm Sifu Ryan Scott
it's good to see you seafood
yes sir nice to officer I am frightened
that my niece is going to get taken take
a look at her over there the Albanians
they're gonna take her I need you to
turn me into a killing machine see what
you do so Albania
what would I do if I'm chained to a pipe
like this just a jump in fun case
oh that's it Gillian come here here here
lay on the ground put your arm up like
you're chained to a radiator so you
kidnapped her can you say something in
an Eastern European accent can you be
like you are my property you are now on
property no way Jose Oh
what if Kevin's not me and he's come out
to the night what would you do sure do
Bennett nananana yeah oh I gave my
necktie oh oh
seafood I don't know
jyllian bra yeah
Sifu Scott taught me some good tactics
but I needed to learn more about these
Albanian monsters so I went to the law
officer Bert I want to thank you for
being here no problem how often do you
get a call it's like officer Burke we've
got some rogue Albanians never how many
times have you shot an Albanian never
how often you tase an Albanian
never in your professional opinion what
are the odds of someone getting taken in
Eastern Europe probably very small
follow-up question what are the odds of
that same person getting taken again
probably zero you're probably right I
was getting nowhere with officer
mustache I needed to get to the source
and speak to a real Albanian sex
trafficker the search took longer than
expected but soon I was staring straight
into the face of pure Albanian evil
where are you from Mexico you're not
from Albania no I'm from Mexico go estas
bien D - what's up guys just get an
Albanian you know who Liam Neeson is
nope I don't know I sure learned a lot
did you learn anything was it worth it
should we have done our looper bit
instead are you an Albanian person is
very upset with me let us know in the
comment section below as always it's
your show guys so let us know what you
want to see next week Christopher Walken
+ honey booboo see you next time on how
Rudnik bye bye I posted another ad
seeking people who legitimately didn't
like the Avengers what I discovered was
horrifying
you saw the Avengers yes what do you
think of the film um I thought it sighs
I think I expected more I don't like it
that much